it's like you want to be abused i don't
understand
he's wearing the shirt i actually very
much like it's hands drawn on with
cigarettes that's very cool
it's not really your brand we know you
don't smoke cigarettes
um he's wearing how do you know he
doesn't smoke cigarettes at him
it's always the nerdiest thing you're
right i know that type of smoker you're
talking about he's not that typical he's
also done
every other drug on the like wait am i
wrong did you ever smoke
uh only casually oh my god what is only
casually
just at parties
no really like how like i'd look like a
little child
you would look like i looked when i was
like at the actually i probably looked
older than you when i was like a teen
at the mall just smoking outside you
look like a young russian teen
but there's so many other things you can
do to look cool that won't like hurt
your lungs nothing's cooler than her
like
i don't know uh like okay like
um drinking a smoothie
at night at night at night when the
sugar
it will keep you up but you don't care
no you are
you know what your bad baby thing is is
that you eat sugar at night that is like
your parents will probably like no more
last night i had like a little big ass
thing of like a tart
i found a vegan soft serve that was tart
and i went
in and i could not sleep i was up all
night
it was it was cray cray
speaking of soft serve you guys heard of
the whole
demi lovato debacle at the yogurt shop
right yeah
what are you guys thought she goes in
she says that
on her way to pay for her yogurt or on
her way
to serve herself yogurt she sees um what
is it like diet
or diet foods in the aisle and it says
like
it triggered her a mental health crisis
for her
yeah i go to like honestly the thing
that annie said a couple weeks ago
like you have to really have
you have to be able to be in control of
what triggers you and you need to
cope yeah if there's no you can't like
okay so she walks into this
to the frozen yogurt sort of get frozen
yogurt but i love her that is
amazing i don't love her i don't care
about her at all and i don't give a [ __ ]
like
songs i don't know which song is her
song bobby listens to her ballads every
night so we do love the music
anyone that i tell you i do not i
know nothing about demi lovato here's my
beef with it
is that i had a friend my friend husto
used to work at
the big chill and i just imagine husta
who barely speaks english
having to deal with a [ __ ] entitled
little i mean he is in our country
well he's like trying to just ring her
up you know what i mean like i don't
like adult tantrums
it's not what i'm into i would
i and also she attacked a small business
but she was wrong
she was also wrong like what she was
saying right it was like
it was sugar-free and diabetics
and and gluten-free which is for people
celiac probably said like skinny or
something on it i don't even think it
did i literally think and they were like
and she was like oh i should have
thought that first before i went on this
territory it's like
no again it's like you are all you have
in control in your life
all you have control of is yourself and
how you react to things things
trigger all of us but we have no control
over that we just have
control over handling our triggers right
that's literally all you can do and when
you grow up
and you realize this and you go to
therapy and you work on yourself it's
that's up to you because if not
you're just like an unsheathed sword
just like slicing everyone around you
you're [ __ ] everyone else up
because you're i always say twiggered
because you're being a baby when you're
triggered so just you remind yourself
every time i am i go i'm twiggered
because then you snap out of it it's
just no one else's problem it's your
problem yeah lamey
i feel bad like i also have had an
eating disorder and i know she struggles
with that
so i understand i i've been in a
position where i'm i see something food
related and i'm triggered
but that's up to me to cope and not to
point fingers and be mad at other people
and
i mean like yeah what you said that that
does suck that she's attacking a small
business although on the flip side i
don't think that place has
ever seen this much press like this and
the yogurt shop
ended up looking good in the whole case
also the way she flipped out on them and
was like i'm gonna come for you i feel
like she's had some kind of
threat to them is someone who's like not
well right right like you're threatening
a little yogurt shop like i think you're
off your meds or whatever
they should rename it demi lovato's as
seen on demi lovato's
instagram uh twitter instagram yeah
it's just an interesting thing where
it's like also who cares like i don't
know
also who cares if she complains about it
it's like yeah
yeah but if you're right to pop off and
be a crazy person if she wants
yeah but that's the [ __ ] up thing is
telling a small business like
i'm gonna come for you yeah you know
yeah
that's you don't that's punching down i
believe i don't believe in punching down
i just you only punch up i only punch up
at me
i put you on a stool now i put on a tall
stool and i punch up
i love your nails i'm never been happier
with my nails in my entire life where
did you get those barbies
i got them at this i went to this nail
salon near my new place by the beach
annie by the beach and it was looked
like a [ __ ]
which is my favorite type of nail salon
and i went in
and i liked the ladies nails she had
these nails i want give me what you have
and she just gave me the guy that did
her nails and then he just did them
exactly
they look so cute they hurt so bad
there's a lot of blood but
the blood heals and they look so cute it
looks like if we had a sleepover that
you i would ask you first to scratch my
head
i know and then the little bugs oh are
you wait are you
into then yeah they would take the
little bugs and she'd make them fight
each other
we wouldn't we wouldn't do well then
because i like my head scratch you like
it's like like the same part of the
chicken yeah you know like
i'm going to be like it's not going to
work i'm just here like this
yeah you're going to be doing that i
also like this if you take like a
compass the the sharp part
and you just order like a mechanical
pencil and you just like
pretend like you're drawing ever so
gingerly on the back on my back
that'll put me to sleep i'd love for you
to do that too yeah annie
oh my gosh you pretty much begged for it
with those nails
i did think of randy i was like randy's
gonna be so happy dude dogs like to be
scratched though i feel like whenever i
touch my dog she runs away
even in the back of her special little
vagina are you scratching oh annie
she does have a cute little vagina she's
not sexual
oh i wanted to ask you so what's an
example of an adult tantrum
demi lovato yeah um i think we see it
more and more now it's like
karen's somebody not getting their way
and having such a fit about it
instead of just like learning to wrangle
your feelings about
being told no and then just walking away
like to me i don't understand what's so
difficult about
like being rejected in the moment and
saying okay well
that's a no going home like why does it
always have to be
it's such a narcissistic move for her to
be like
oh this is like an attack on my eating
disorder or whatever when obviously if
she took one second to think about it
it's for people that have
food allergies that isn't [ __ ]
nothing well she thinks she's rallying
for a cause that's
what's even more twisted about it she
thinks that she is
you know the commander of all of the
other girls who are suffering from
eating disorders and it's like look
i was i was bulimic for six years i it
was so bad for me that i had ants on the
rim of my toilet
like my chicken she was eating some good
sweets if the ants were coming
is your throat [ __ ] up it is [ __ ] up
i had the ugliest
worst eating disorder which there you
never did anything like that
hot girls do i just ate way too much and
couldn't stop
but then i didn't like throw up i just
was a binge eater
so i just if anyone wanted to be more
attracted to me today
there you go but then you just well
that's good like you never graduated to
actually like destroying your body i
didn't even know there was such thing as
plates i was like we all eat over trash
cans right
wait what we just yeah you just eat over
trash cans
my family all is like such binge eaters
though it's like i have been i've gotten
to a place of real
especially since my last family vacation
of real like
acceptance of how much laughter um
making food bad has given me and my
family like we've made so many foods bad
and then we go
my dad has a he calls it what does he
call it like the
the drive the wall of shame where he
drives this is littering too by the way
but my dad will go to the grocery store
get a bunch of like jelly beans
eat as many as he can and then on this
one exit on the highway
he just throws the rest out and there's
just idiot drive by
like cupcakes and like he just has a
trash pile of all things that he's like
my parents are always like putting soap
on food like they'll get a cake and
they'll shove it down the
garbage disposal and i always was like
kind of struggling with the shame around
like binge eating they're not eating
a lot or whatever and then this last
vacation we had so many laughs over
shoving cake in our mouths that i
realized like icing has really
is the glue that brings my family
together and just i have no more
there's no more shame see that's how i
know your parents must have money
because
my parents would never in a million
years destroy
a piece of food they would never throw
something out the window my mom will eat
halloween candy that's not a money thing
though they can't
eat they can't stop themselves from
eating it it's not a money thing i know
what you mean
though esther because like my mom is one
of those when we were raised
not a morsel left on the plate like food
was never thrown out and
every single bit of leftovers had to be
eaten
if it's half moldy bread you cut out the
moldy part and you eat the other half
there was no there was no time for food
to get moldy mouth like if there's
a binge eating like everything's being
eaten it's like it's like from
beginning to cake to end of cake if
there's any cake left it's getting
shoved
down because they don't want to eat it
it's not about like saving money
that's the better way to do it yeah you
cannot like you need to throw cupcakes
away whether it's in you or out of you
it's still not good for anybody so it's
like
a lot caught in yeah honestly when i
moved here it was benji
that taught me that concept i like
couldn't remember
he was like you you destroy the food
that's left and i just was like i don't
understand what do you why
how could you destroy food i don't
understand i will tell you this
a lot of my childhood memories are like
watching my dad like peel pancakes off
the bottom of plates and stuff like
just digging back to grab it i've gone
i've eaten food out of the trash
that george costanza episode the episode
of seinfeld where he eats the eclair out
of the trash is like
i was like what's so weird and funny
about this do you guys and i told you
with the syrup i already told you guys
my dad would chug like
aunt jemima's but i just have come to
this like complete like
turnaround where i'm just like this is
so funny my family's like this we just
like laugh and laugh
and i mean like todd will sometimes like
he'll put oreos up high so i can't get
them
and so i have to take a knife to like
get them and he'll come in and see me in
the kitchen with a knife
and he starts slamming like it looks
like a slasher film i'm trying to get
he's knocking the knife out of my hand
and we're like crying laughing it's like
the hardest i
will laugh ever and it's like so many
people are like
oh no i'm becoming my parents i am this
this past month i've realized like i am
exactly my parents
and it's so cute at my peak i had
family just trying holding my hand and
like
visit i remember we were at the beach in
this beach called malball in the
philippines and there's this treat
called hopia
and they come in like little roll
packets and i had just dusted off like
eight packets at that point and they
were
i was just in a corner just shoving
shoving shoving because it tasted so
good because i deprived myself
now i'm binge yeah now i'm gonna now i'm
gonna puke it up
it takes takes a village too that's like
the key that was what actually really
helped me when i went to my eating
disorder
program was it's like the pendulum will
always swing in the opposite direction
so like
i would try not to eat and then i would
feel really good about myself but then
like
if you don't eat like what goes up must
come down it's like the pendulum swings
and then you
stuff your face like it's 6 p.m or
whatever and that's like that was my
cycle too
my cycle is that and then over
exercising oh wow
like that's how that was
a lot of like collegiate and high school
wrestlers eventually
have eating disorders because they
always have to like weigh themselves and
they have to be
you know at their they when during
weigh-ins they can't be more than
like a pound esther will find out soon
when she does her weigh-in with
wood jewels the jewels what's the latest
to come commentate wait how what's the
catch how much do you weigh us sir
i so i 100 pounds in my head i weigh 105
but apparently in my last doctor's
appointment i was like
quite a bit more liars they lied to you
i was like 115 which i don't believe
oh perfect you guys can be um straw
weight 115 is a legitimate ufc
weight division it's called straw weight
that is a really
humiliating name strawweight the straw
that you guys are so little that you're
the straw that broke the camel's back
the rest of us are camels if you go back
down to 105 it's adam
adam wait how do you know this because
i'm a
mma freak i like literally you guys know
i wanted to
not take joe rogan's job but 15 years
ago when i was about
20 years old i contacted the ufc because
i wanted to be a ringside commentator so
i thought you were trying to get on fear
factor
or to be like one of the aren't there
like ring girls
no not the ring girls i wanted to know
not the ring girl she wanted to be in
there
no because i i was obsessed with mma i
watched a lot of like pride
early ufc and stuff like that so like i
knew all like the stats of like fighters
and stuff
and um i wanted to be that that was my
life goal was to be
joe rogan sidekick and to be a boy it
never happened
i wouldn't ever want to be a boy i went
to one ufc game and i
never have eaten so many nachos it was i
was so honest do you remember who fought
no you're like me at like a dance club
where i'm like
some clubs like serve like snacks not
like peanut butter sandwiches
really oh wow yeah that actually sounds
like you're drunk you've been dancing
yeah that sounds like it would be so
satiating is that the word
satiating satiating satisfying
yeah you took the [ __ ] out oh my god
this is me wanting to be
jerome oh my god it looks like fear
factor by the way have you had plastic
surgery
no this is before plastic surgery what
plastic surgery have you had
i just my boobs oh this is before my oh
my god george my god
your face looks different like asian
would be the fourth thing i thought you
were
asian really yeah it would be down the
list i'm so full i want to say that i've
actually eaten so much mcdonald's just
out of like the
you have the amount of time that i've
had to eat just because we've been
moving and stuff i've eaten so much
mcdonald's that i literally feel like
i'm in super size me
it's getting ridiculous just running out
of time or just like all right we'll go
to mcdonald's
moving is exhausting i'm just not
somebody i know watching the guys we
paid to do it was just like
oh painful are you somebody that when
you move
are you somebody are you a hoarder do
you have hoarding tendencies or you just
throw away the stuff you don't need
anymore i throw away a lot bipolar about
it it's like
depending on the mood i'm either in the
mood and everything goes or like
everything stays i'm just a baby about
it
well there's some boxes like i gotta be
real about where i'm like this isn't
gonna
make it into the cabinets but i'm like
i'll just deal with it later so i came
up with a remedy
what at home um tiny things i call it
chichi burichi or
aka the [ __ ] box things that don't
belong anywhere and things where i'm too
lazy to sort of sort and find a place
for
just gets thrown in a [ __ ] box and
if i can't find something around the
house
that's my that's the last place yeah it
must be the [ __ ] that's really smart
i need to get one of those i've done um
i mean every drawer of mine is a junk
drawer it always happens like it takes
about a month into moving and
everything is like oh there are scissors
and there's
like um scissors are our tough item
i never know where those are they also
are a good pla they're i never know
kitchen well you have some in the
bathroom one in the bathroom one in the
kitchen
you trim your pubes with like normal
scissors yeah i do
what do you have special pube trimming
scissors it's called a
razor i don't trim my oh wait do not cut
before you shave
why would i do that i just trim a little
bit and then i use the manscape to take
it down to a one
or a zero and that's my um
my ritual
what do you think about pubes when i see
a man
properly um groom down there i feel like
he cares about me a little bit more
oh that's good to know
our sponsors at manscaped the best in
men's below the waist grooming have
just launched their fourth generation
trimmer the lawnmower
4.0 and yes that's right the 4.0 and i
know that bobby sort of is a heathen but
there's one thing that he keeps very
very
um pristine is his down there and that's
because
my boyfriend uses manscaped and it has
saved our relationship saved it
i no longer get a mouthful of pubes i'm
very happy about that it's kind of
awesome that manscaped engineered the
ultimate groin and body trimmer by
focusing on intelligent functionality
and an incredibly
comfortable grooming experience their
fourth generation trimmer
features a cutting-edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents thanks to
their advanced
skin safe technology it includes a
multi-function
on and off switch that can engage a
travel lock and also gives your man the
ability
the ability to turn the 4000k led
spotlight
on and off well you get a [ __ ]
spotlight oh my god i need that
that's that's key i need that's key
bush off let's go so you get the
spotlight when needed for more precise
shave his balls are in good care with a
4.0
make sure your balls are magnum kulati
ladies this is the perfect gift for you
and your man and trust me he will thank
you and man your balls will thank you
listen this is the only 4.0 i've ever
gotten all right
and let's just you guys too be a good
student of your own balls get 20
off and free shipping with a cold
bloodbath at manscape.com that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com
with the code bloodbath heat up your sex
life with landscape
today's episode is sponsored by blue
chew blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in a chewable form
at a fraction of the cost blue chews
tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erections to combat all
forms of ed erectile dysfunction blue
chew is an
online prescription service so no visits
to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations and no waiting in
line at the pharmacy and it ships right
to your door in a discreet package no
bending down and coughing gentlemen
okay the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information and
obviously we have a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code bathgirls at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code bathgirls
to receive your first
month free and we thank bluechu for
sponsoring this podcast and offering
such a good deal
i know free boners we're giving you free
boners what i was going to say do you
ever like sometimes
i'll pack up a bunch of stuff that i'm
getting rid of and i'll like throw it in
a big garbage bag and then like
it goes to you know get ready to go to
donation
and one time i forgot to bring it to
and so it was in my trunk and like i had
completely forgot about it and then i
opened the trunk and was like
my things yeah all my things like i was
so happy to like go through them again
which is so pathetic
like a lost treasure yeah yeah my
problem is
when i try to take um stuff to donate
like my mom always comes
she comes once a week and she always
fusses she's like yeah you got to clear
your claws you got to clear your life
and i don't have a lot of things but
she's a
clearer upper that she doesn't like um
things that don't have a place she wants
a belt and she wants rock salt and
that's
all she wants she's like you have two
hours go through that closet and start
and i never finished a task i come out
with a [ __ ] luchador mask
yeah yeah things that i'm now finding
treasures more and more things that i
will absolutely never throw away and it
just
pisses her off to no end and i'm in a
full like rey mysterio
you know wwe outfit yeah and she's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing i have so
many props like i have the wwe belt like
as a fanny pack i have like
ric flair socks i've never worn i mean i
just have i have fake tongues i have
like
i have a gavel that's plastic i have
five swords like
i have like todd's like where are we
putting the swords and i was like i
don't know am i still a sword girl like
i don't know
i have costumes i have like a tutu a
wedding dress i have like stripper
clothes like i have all these random for
like
i just think that i'm gonna have a big
costume opportunity
well you found it and is the opportunity
to have a stripper episode i can
honestly imagine you getting married in
a tutu
and can't imagine anything else i was
thinking today
i was like i would maybe have a wedding
if i could do like a big musical theater
number
like a big musical theater review
performance for my
for my beloved all your guests are like
yeah again here we go yes you're doing
like a high kick
there's an encore i have to do a flash
mob like no one can know about it no
flash mob
that's very surprise everyone with that
that's very precious diana of you
really why very princess diana because
when she felt like she was losing
charles this is what i watched in the
crown
she put up a theater performance so like
on their anniversary
the first time on her anniversary she
did like uh
they watched the play together and um
she went down the stairs and as the
the play was like closing up she did a
dance number for him in front of
everyone and he was humiliated by it
i would have been so humiliated the next
anniversary she was like okay i [ __ ]
that one up
i'm going to do it privately so as a
gift her gift to him
was a a performance like a film dance
performance
are you serious and he also was not a
fan of that yeah she was
obviously it was like forcing that on i
mean i would be
if nothing worse nobody wants that eye
contact with the dance but even like
getting lap dances at strip clubs i'm
like i mean also i'm not i'm not that
attracted to women i mean it's a little
bit but when their bodies are on me i'm
like i'm not
but it's just like so awkward for him
like it's too much like
exact attention on me i don't know i
don't know have you been to sam's
i know george has been to sam's sam
sam's club i
have that place um you guys you've been
to strip clubs right
yeah yeah i'm definitely not a stiff
there i feel like i come alive
me too when we go to vegas if we ever
plan it
i would love to go to strip club we get
each other some lap dances
maybe there's like a room where we all
go who were you mad at not playing it
all of us i heard a little bit george
yeah yeah i heard that too i heard that
george
was it wasn't secret i want to plan it
can i just say something also about
george that
i don't want this to get missed he's
wearing pink shorts and they're not
salmon-colored pink they're like make
fun of this [ __ ] barbie pink
they're this pink
and then purple socks and green shoes
thanks by color
do you guys know that george went to
colombia and got drugged and robbed
and it wasn't just any kind of it wasn't
even like um
what do you call it um date rape he
there's this thing called burudanga
and it's a drug where if you slip it in
somebody or it's like if
it's like it can be inhaled or like
absorbed it can be it could be ingested
ingested absorbed what's it called
devil's breath basically you don't he
doesn't look
um inebriated or intoxicated he doesn't
it blacks him out but he's still acting
normally
so if you look at all his hotel footage
he looks like just a regular guy going
back in his hotel with somebody with a
stranger he doesn't know and the dude
[ __ ] robbed him off of everything
including your passport no
uh no my passport was at the hotel like
i you look so robbable
i i would rob the [ __ ] out of you i am
not a thief i would leave
stuff i would just take it and throw it
out
the mustache you've got a mustache no
too i mean this is a wrapable man
i like that boradanga that's so scary
that's scary
oh man i went to college it sounds very
similar to a lot of people i know
i i got drugged in an island called
baraka in the philippines
um and it was not fun i ended up in the
hospital
unraped thankfully very unraped because
i there was an intervention somebody
a friend of mine saw like a dude
carrying me like i was like he was
i was obviously lost my footing and he
saw a dude
um bringing me back to the room and he
basically stopped it right there
because everyone had been listening and
then he took you and then someone else
was like whoa whoa whoa
they're just like yeah i kept passing
michael passed around
i thought i was on rape and he might
have no i like that you never get raped
but everyone
keeps trying to save you to then rape
you but then someone else saves you and
finally like a buff woman like your mom
comes and saves you
and that's how you met bobby and then
bob and then bobby saved you
he can't carry me you take care of me
there's mystery wet spots in the morning
so rough like pee or something what is
this
what's the worst mystery wet spot i
think it would be pee
no peeing the bag
someone else's semen okay
or it's like oh my god was i a squirter
but i was blacked out yeah
the first time i squirted i wasn't even
there for it demon doesn't really cause
a wet spot it's more like a crusty
they're crusty yeah
do you guys get like wow you just left
do you guys get wet dreams
no i don't understand what that is um
when you have an orgasm in your sleep
i thought it was for guys notes for
girls too let me tell you
have you do you really think the things
that happened to guys wouldn't happen to
you
[Laughter]
but it's wet dream because nocturnal
emission
because the go-go comes out that's what
makes it good yeah but
make sure that google and go go but not
no yes but not like when they go
go oh she's nervous they don't have a
go-go that comes out when they go go do
you know do you feel me
why is everyone looking at me like i am
about to explode
what there's no well there's no obvious
you know seminal fluid but we got you
know the wet panties
for people yeah stuff comes out yeah
stuff comes out
esther's like i've never had an orgasm
[Laughter]
she's like wait that's what no we're
just looking at to see if you have an
epiphany
no one is looking at you in a bad way
we're really waiting but
you i would think it's like squirting is
what you're referring to
no not squirting because you can orgasm
without you know where you like after
you come
it's it's more there's more of something
there there's a little there's yeah
and that would be considered a wet dream
just
having uh having a sexual dream and then
going
uh having completion having an orgasm
from that
i have i've had them but i'm like a guy
i'm a guy and i'm giving it to a girl
wait are you serious yeah
but i tried it listen guys it's just in
my dreams have you had that kind of
training i have that all the time
where you're a guy i i'm i lucid dream
so i have sex with everyone in my dream
with no regrets and i
orgasm so much in my eyes we actually
call her lou seed
that's her name and the dream i have
i've never dreamt
as a guy well tonight we're giving i'm
placing this on you this will happen
my dreams are like plane crashes and
like i wake up it's and like i have to
go back to school
oh school is the worst school dreams are
like i would rather like a hardcore race
i don't understand your guys's dreams
right now at all
like i don't are we compatible
you're a man [ __ ] a girl and you're
this is your daydream by the way you're
acting you're jealous that
i'm having an actual experience in the
night
i just said so unlike you
to be a man [ __ ] a girl in your dream
that's not who you are
you know that beyonce song that's like
if i was like yeah
that is like i'm like yeah i would
[ __ ] rock that [ __ ] dude
that's why i'm like i always want it's
like how do i get the strap on in and
how it's like maybe just a bang one
chick with a strap on that to me
you know if that feels because i know
i'm like the
the token lesbian and the podcast i know
that
okay i know that i am not completely
a straight line more of a camel token
but that's fine
but that is really to me what you're
saying is
like not straight sounding you're upset
and i'm like
that's my role i feel like oh do you
feel like i'm taking um
thunder because in real life you're so
straight
but in your dreams you sound not so the
lesbian that got me this is how she got
me okay
and she got me by being like
do you think you not thinking you're a
lesbian and not having lesbian feelings
towards people is
how you're a lesbian and i remember
going well i never thought i was gay and
she was like but don't you think that's
because you're gay and you like
deeply repressed it and i was like
maybe but honestly how she got me was
the guy i was [ __ ] was so disgusting
like
he brought us and i told you this i
don't know if i saw this he brought us
in to watch two girls one cup
and she was like excited why even if you
bring that up but she was like taking
like five years to forget that every
time someone mentions that that's how
she became one of the girls and my two
girls one cup life is because
he was like i'm going to show you guys
something and we went into the office at
the bar he was working at
and he showed us two girls one cup and
she's like do you really want to date
men that's really what you want
i was like i'll give it a go but in real
life could you ever see yourself putting
on
a strap-on and having sex with a woman
just
did you just get nervous with that woman
oh i thought that was like an
involuntary like i gagged with a knee i
mean a woman um i mean maybe for the
only fans
oh annie that's not the only fan let's
talk no that's not you're like no that's
from the public
for free no i don't know i'm not i just
don't have like
like sexual like romantic feelings
towards women
except in your dreams in my dreams it's
more it's not really about the woman
that's about me being like the man like
the dominant thing
do you ever say i'm not thinking about a
vagina or anything it's like me just
like being
like a good having a penis kind of yeah
but i don't see the penis you know
dreams are like
a vibe you miss their out certain things
yeah yeah do you have you ever fallen in
love with somebody
in your dream and woken up yes like
forlorn yes
like you'll i'll have like i guess like
sort of a sex dream i wouldn't call it a
wet dream
but like i'll have a dry dream a sex
she's a dry drunk she's a dress
a dream where you hook up with someone
you know and then you wake up and like
for that whole day you're
fully in love with that person but you
never would have been
exactly and it's always random like i
remember i had a swim coach who was like
20 years older than me married yeah
random older dad he's an authority
figure
he helped anything you were really good
at but like i woke up one day and
from a dream and i was like in love with
him for two days and it really made me
uncomfortable i couldn't even go to swim
practice for two days because i was like
until
this is out of my system i can't look
him in the eye it's never who you want
it to be it's never who you wanted
i had two weird i had i lose a dream so
it's always who i wanted
i gave myself yeah i gave myself dreams
about like my friend matt who we called
when i set a crush on him i would make
myself dream
how how do you do that before i go to
bed i'll be like dream of matt dreamo
matt drew my mate dream event and i
would just make myself if it was the
last thing i thought of i would always
dream about him
but i had a dream about my
middle school teacher mr jones my math
teacher who was so nice so supportive so
cool
great teacher i had a dream that he
tried to tongue kiss me and his
tongue was slit like a snake i
never went back and visited that school
and said hello to him again like he like
his perfect image is my
one of my favorite teachers was ruined
because he was a scary molester snake in
my dream and i've had that too like
where i had a
uh at an apartment club because i lived
in santa fe there was a
one of the groundskeepers i had a very
lucid dream that i had those slot
um coverings for the windows and i left
my
door open so it was just the wind was
coming through and it was smacking
and i had this lucid dream where i was
actually there
and he this is what it felt like i don't
know if this is what a lucid dream is
and he was coming through that window
and
like put and like raping like he put his
neck his hand on my neck to reap
the scariest like more than things that
have actually happened to me in real
life
the scariest moment of my life i woke up
he wasn't there
but i never let anyone i just had like
leaky faucets and stuff for the rest of
the time
i never let anyone in my apartment again
that's crazy and he did nothing to me
like he just was like a guy that was
there
lucid dreaming esther is basically
having control of
your dream and knowing it's a dream
while staying
in realm or in that stage of sleep so
like for instance
if i'm being chased by some a murderer i
can say
this is a dream this isn't real calm
myself down
have a strategy and then play in that
dream realm
it's so cool like knowing it's a dream
that's funny can we give you like a
dream we want you to have about us and
see if you can do it
yeah i in fact i could probably have sex
with both of you
in my dream and feel like no remember
that's how that's
i never cheated on bobby never will
because i have that ability to have sex
with whoever i want
i have reoccurring dreams of being
behind the starting blocks
and being in lane four being expected to
win a race
and then me looking around saying like i
haven't swam in 20 years
everyone knows and you know everyone's
saying you're the best from the stands
you're the best you got this let's go
isn't it funny that her dreams are
people her nightmares are people
screaming are the best
that's how good she was that's how
[ __ ] good she was but her that it's
so ingrained in her
um but those are similar to this school
yeah i'm like i can't
do this anymore why lane four do you
know lane four is the fastest
thing yeah you have to do that you have
to be seated so if you go in
like big meets you can't just join right
like you have to follow
five and then four and five three four
five are the fastest but lane four is
michael phelps
oh okay yeah so if you're at the top um
if you're the fastest person qualifying
into that race then you're in the middle
my brother okay so my twin brother we
were all on the swim team even my mom by
the way she just joined the one day my
mom was dropping us off at swim practice
and just came with us and had a swimsuit
on and just was on the team
is that legal it was so well there's an
unlimited group so we were like
you know we were probably 10 and under
at that point is that when she did did
she do water aerobics next door no
she was on the [ __ ] swim team
swimming against 15 year olds
so there's 14 and under and then there's
unlimited which is like 15 and up but
it's supposed to be like 15 16
17. you know what i mean not a matter of
my mom she was like
found a loophole and that's what i found
a loophole her pubes through her [ __ ]
it was like she had like it was so
embarrassing and it was just like mom
what it's like so weird
and she's like trying to beat like 15
year old she was like competitive that
would be my jam
i would love to join like a dance class
for kids
yeah no you are i think when we get in
places because you're my mom
i think you trigger mommy problems in my
heart really
i i don't think i've heard enough about
your mom to feel like
it's not like her it's like i think it's
like a
like a thing i don't get from her i
don't get from you or something
that's really deep this weekend i was
hanging out with my buddy spearfishing
and i took my pants out to get into my
sweat uh
my um my wetsuit but i had to be in a
bikini
and they all just did this they're like
kalyla
talk about side bush they were so
disappointed in me
like have you just given up permission
to tell about whitney's pool party
whitney has spontaneous pool parties
okay none of us are shave none of us are
ready
yeah but whitney is also friends with us
and then like
movie stars who are like lasered and
gorgeous and perfect
so like whitney will just have swimsuits
like pool party time there was a an
outfit oh yeah
just remind me i don't care i was
remember when she put you in the long
sleeve one
oh yeah it looked terrible and then it
was it was bikini cut but let's just say
it looked like long shorts
i never wear swimsuits i i we've talked
about this like i only wear shorts and a
t-shirt because i just
can't be held responsible for what's
going on
in between my legs like the hair is pube
level
from like the pube area to a few inches
below
like the thighs are pube type yeah you
know what
i get the same and that's why my buddies
my buddy this weekend when he was like
dude like
oh you're organized i was guys not girls
well yeah my my sister was there but it
was my buddy who was like holy [ __ ]
kaleila like have you just given up
that's so funny but it's also like it's
not for you
sometimes i feel like feminists like
that and then he pointed out this mole
on my thigh because i haven't shaved my
legs either he pointed a mole in my
thigh that had two coarse hairs sticking
out oh i hate that
and he was like what about that one but
don't you kind of like it to have a mold
that's like a thing it's like no project
to go back to you know
you know it's a healthy one my mom
always says oh it has hair in it that's
a good one don't take it out is that
real though i don't know
this episode is sponsored by apostrophe
a prescription
skin care company for people that are
ready to take their acne
seriously prescription acne treatment
really works but it's hard to get you
have to take time
off to see a doctor and you sit in line
at the pharmacy for your medications
until
you guys apostrophe apostrophe makes it
easy to see a board
certified dermatologist online you'll
get treated immediately and your
medications are delivered to your home
and simply fill out apostrophe's online
questionnaire about your skin concerns
and medical history
then just snap a few selfies and your
dermatologist will get back to you with
a customized treatment plan tailored
just for you
apostrophe treats acne and they can also
help you hit your other skincare goals
like reducing redness wrinkles and even
dark spots
that's what i have problems with dark
spots my melasma redness for me
oh i don't have any issues i really have
great skin but it's because of
apostrophe
no but honestly as a good skincare
routine can really change your game
and if you struggle with any of these
issues apostrophe is such a good service
because
it's easy to use and it's affordable and
it's tailored to you it's not like
you're not just going to the store and
just guessing
i think it's also just really convenient
to sort of have this like
dermatologist um like a virtual
dermatologist yeah but they're a real
dermatologist correct
and that's why they're able to prescribe
you oral medications as well
and honestly i got used to during kova
not having to go to the pharmacy so it's
really nice that apostrophe just sends
everything straight to your door
get 15 off your first visit with a
board-certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com
bathgirls and use your code bathgirls
this code is only available to our
listeners
to get started just go to apostrophe.com
bathgirls
and click begin visit then use code
bathgirls at sign up and you'll get 15
off your dermatologist 15 off that's
like almost imposter
free that's a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e-d.com
bathgirls and use that code bathgirls to
get your dermatology visit for 15
off and we thank apostrophe for
sponsoring this podcast and honestly
going to see a dermatologist like this
is a non-negotiable it's something you
should do
regularly anyways i highly recommend
checking out apostrophe
kala you're always dressed so cute you
want to know my secret
yes stitch fix wait really
i love stitch fix i have so much fun on
stitch fix you guys shopping for new
clothes can be
needlessly stressful so why not let
stitch fix
make it easy by doing the work for you
so you can spend time doing other things
you love instead
esther's a great delegator and my mom
wrote all my papers in college so do you
think either of us want to pick out our
own clothes
no we don't getting stitch fix really
helps me sort of like
re-enter society because i don't even
have to think about
um which what to shop for i don't like
thinking i don't like making the choices
stitch fix has someone else make it for
you
and then you're cute and you didn't even
have to really try and you only keep the
stuff you love
you can send everything back stitch fix
has free shipping easy returns and
exchanges and a prepaid return envelope
is included
honestly after i tried stitch fix i was
like this is the easiest way
to get new stuff i've ever encountered
and also guys it's not just for women
this is also for men
there's some bobby uses yes bobby uses
stitch fix yeah um there's no
subscription required
try stitch fix once or set up automatic
deliveries you'll pay just twenty
dollars of a styling fee for each box
which gets credited towards pieces you
keep
and there are no hidden fees ever get
started today at stitchfix.com
bathgirls and you'll get 25 off when you
keep everything in your fix that's
stitchfix.com girls
for 25 percent off when you keep
everything in your fix
stitchfix.com bathgirls
faster my mission honestly when we do a
swimsuit episode i am not
i am going to keep my side bush there
and i'm going to just
when you say side bush it sounds to me
like it's only like it's parted to one
side
like you're doing like a side part like
one side will be clean and the rest is
pushed over
listen when we do the bikini episode i'm
gonna accidentally be out of town
i don't know what you guys are [ __ ]
up to you guys are crazy
and also i'm gonna look at that i'm
gonna come in fully spray tan
like i mean i've gotten filler in my uh
cellulite
that's a new thing on all of my abs
you know i think that that's not a bad
tactic to just sort of
not draw in your abs but like contour
your ass yes
i'm not into that i don't like fake it's
like
i don't you either well i don't want to
have it to show people i have it i want
to have it for myself
right so are we talking about a bush i'm
so confused what are we talking about
which part you're exactly like my mom my
mom has a 16 pack
and i'm like ma you never wear like a
two-piece bikini
she was like you think i do this for
other people it's for me
i was like all right [ __ ] you're like
really it feels like a personal attack
to me [ __ ] because i have now an
exercise problem trying to look like you
i don't like fake grass either i know
you i think you have someone now i feel
rude
but she always have big tips we record
on that fake grass
i prefer even though fake grass i think
i have a love hate with it because
it is beautiful and i every time i see
it i'm like it's so beautiful
but i like refuse it because it's so
unnatural
one of the biggest arguments bobby and i
had was regarding that grass back there
because it's so like
overly manicured and it doesn't have
like a natural thing about it but
also it does save me from allergies and
it does save me from having to
water that grass yeah it's it's good for
the environment
we just got a bunch of fake plants and i
was like fighting with todd about i was
like it's just
i know i kill plants i know i like
randy's the only thing i've kept alive
like i
i know that but it's like they look like
[ __ ] and yours don't look like that bad
but
it's like ours look bad i'm like this
looks [ __ ] terrible
i can see like seams in my plants well
then you can i think the
more expensive ones are better you sound
like you bought some dollar store [ __ ]
i went to ikea it's like todd and i are
like because we're
like leveling up monetarily it's like
we're trying to like figure
out what's real and what's not like
what's like old patterns and what isn't
because todd just got this like really
sick job on netflix it's just like
really exciting so
we moved into this new place and he's
like let's get fake plants and i'm like
is this like
old us or like even ikea i was like
can't we go to like cb2 or something
i love cpt i want to go to cb2 and we
also try to like get our like
styles together it's just like different
styles annie came over once
when i like got my first sample pair of
sweatpants
and i wanted to like fit them on
different sized bodies
because i'm short and so she came over
and so we're like sitting in the
standing in the backyard and like she
was trying them on and dave was
uh on an actual like real job he was in
his writer's room zoom
and annie i'm like do it do it
and she just takes off all her clothes
and he's like dancing in front of dave
and he was so upset there's nothing
funnier than like flashing someone and
then being really upset
yeah like it's just like a perfect it
just i know everyone enjoy except dave
i know and then he's cause he's the same
way with whitney
like sometimes we'd facetime whitney and
she just answered tits out
and we're not even it's like [ __ ]
spread like we've seen insides of
whitney
dave gets so upset he's like so
uncomfortable
and i don't care i'm like whoever wants
to show my boyfriend naked stuff
go for it i i'm not that's how i feel
too i'm like i don't care
well stuff for whitney all the time and
it's like he has just probably
so much footage of naked and it's just
she says it herself she's like don't
worry my personality kills it and i'm
like
you're right would you care about that
like bobby seeing like girls naked does
that bother you
um and what what what what context like
let's say just simply like me and annie
were here we were naked
oh god no no no no no no jenna is always
naked around the house
really yeah she's another one that
flashes yeah she's always like
[ __ ] up into the sky in her backyard
trying to tan like a random part of her
body
and like eating like elote or like corn
on the cob in the backyard
and bobby just walks past her talks to
her like she's not even naked but
bobby's sort of a nudist himself so
it doesn't faze him um and yeah if bobby
were to care about other people being
naked i would be like
excuse me i've never seen bobby naked
have you have
you are serious were you ever with him
in the
five years ago ever any minute i've seen
bobby's balls several times
several several times because his dad
used to walk around the house naked
with just a string of toilet paper
coming out of his butt that's why he was
called the korean kite
because he had like a leaky butt as he
was getting older and he would like
beat bobby's mom and like beat the kids
and then he would like rage out like
naked with just this little thing like
flying out of his butt and so
bobby sort of like mimics his dad in
that way but honestly i'm not gonna lie
to you talk about asian home
we're always half naked we're always
walking around in like underwear and
todd's mom
facetimes us like with the thing like
just over her nipples and i'm like
i can't tell you how much i love that
you are calling your son naked i
i just love her so much like i take the
phone from him now and i'm like
enough of you and we just like go around
she like i told her that i called her
annoying on the pocket she was like send
it to me
it feels like it's very real between you
guys listen can i just say i met todd's
mom
dad uncles like everyone i loved
everyone like all of them it's my
parents came there you guys just got a
new place like
where what's going on it is like the
first time i've gotten a place for
someone where i'm not in a full panic
can i like be a girl for a second like
what's happening
it even felt boy when you did it like
what do you guys mean you could shower
with your parents
what now anytime
i showered with my parents when i was
young little yeah
do you shower with your siblings or yeah
no max and i did we did baths together
my sister uh told me when i was little
that i
was covered in dead skin cells and she
didn't want to be near me oh
esther that's so that's not very nice
that was like the first little slice of
reality you guys i'll shower with you
no way i shower get making some promises
you're really gonna have to [ __ ]
i shower with everybody can i tell you
something i would love to shower with
you guys i always shower with my friends
yeah and then you know
you're going to schmidt fight i can
flick my stuff at you until you
until you are out
i'm out of here also [ __ ] sharing a
shower
sucks there's nothing like showers
there's not enough warm water for
everybody so then you're like out of it
no you just do a circle because no
you're not okay let me tell you this
when i'm shampooing then my sister or
whoever friend
possibly you is in the shower getting
ready to be shampooed when i need to
wash and you need to shampoo we switch
there is a method i promise my best
friend tara from college
we when we went to chicago to like hang
out with her family for spring break
we were showering in the shower we were
laughing sorry because there's like a
squeegee so one of us would be squeeging
and like your body is all like
soaked up so we're just like laughing
and like slipping off of each other and
squeegeeing it was one of the
that's what i'm saying i feel really
lonely in the shower i like to have
company
jenna and i shower together all the time
does that make you jealous
all the time no again i
i'm sharing is like a challenge for me
i don't want to share my hot water
sweating it's the reason you don't like
showers because it's not enough water
yeah it's not warm enough i'm always
cold you need the bath to hug you
yes the shower for and also i grew up in
a house where the hot water was very
limited like
you know limited access so who got it
first your dad
um i don't know i honestly don't
remember fighting over i feel like
nobody wanted in
and i i recently tweeted about this dave
never showers he and i are so
filthy together and it is such a happy
safe
like concept to me i just love it i'll
look at him and i'll be like when was
your last shower and we just laughed
just like you and your family laugh
about food
we just i look like greasy hair
i yeah todd showers more than i would
like i mean i want people to smell good
i don't
smell bad or anything but he showers so
much it feels like an attack
like i'm like now i'm supposed to shower
and he doesn't care about it exactly
my first but my first like stinky
boyfriend it was such a dream
when i had that first boyfriend that was
like i like his stinky i was like yeah
you do like i i've never i'm like you
know i'm the girl that was like washing
my [ __ ] in the sink everywhere like
everywhere i went i was like if there's
hand soap it's
getting it's going between my legs like
just always like so scared i was like
stinking up the joints i dated someone
who would always sniff my armpits and it
was
it was like funny who was it i'm not
gonna say but you know him
so he is a really cool comedian
um but dave doesn't mind that i'm just
is he but he doesn't seem like a popular
comedian or less popular i'm not
answering that
is he more popular or less i'm not
answering that i'll just know if you
just say more or less no you
i don't think you would actually you
would
i've never married annie is he married
still
i'm not separated that was yes
it's the one it's the third one it's the
one i wasn't thinking of and then i know
no i don't think no it's not no
i forgot that you know about that one
okay let's move on i know it's not that
one
this is cute i like this game guess the
one is it this one or that one
does it scare you that like some people
have all of your information like all of
your secrets everyone
how about when i accidentally remember
you know like you guys my full bank
account all of my
i don't remember that yeah you that's
right you made a mistake you hit reply
all right
just reply all my information i'm like
everyone on this production has my bank
account
but you can't do much with that except
put money into your account i
this is the one i know could do
something yeah i was like
deposit only guys please um should we
take a banana break
[Music]
may i just say you guys that for once
wait what other snacks are there this is
a perfect banana
for once george can somebody wash my
blueberries
oh my god they taste like pesticides you
have to
always say like that though will you pee
can you the organic
blueberries taste like they're not
organic oh they are oh my god i'm a star
did you think they weren't gonna get you
organic afterwards
esther how was phoenix so
much fun i you guys i was so nervous
like because i hadn't obviously done the
road in over almost
probably almost two years and i was
really really nervous
but all those stupid-ass zoom comedy
shows i did
like all the material that i wrote for
those ended up translating
so well way better you're like your
mic's on
i and so i did everything i did was new
material
like everything from the special is
obviously long gone and then
my 92 year old aunt was there my
grandma's sister
and i brought her on stage and i asked
her questions like about what i was like
when i was little
oh i'd like to get my hands on that i
know is this the
she's the sister to the grandmother that
doesn't like you the one you never met
the one that doesn't like me
are you sure she doesn't like you i mean
my mom says i have to stop saying this
but
she probably reminds you of her or
something no we're nothing alike
she doesn't i don't know whatever but
sounds like a real [ __ ] [ __ ]
well don't say that i'm kidding i'm
joking she has a disease
she's sounding more like you know
um but yeah it was really fun
i don't know how was the comedy store i
have a question did you do your purse
thing
i did i went through two purses esther's
purse
moves are unmatched thank you on your
special
i watched all of esther well maybe i
missed one of those i think you were
there for the whole time i think i saw
both of
them the one where you took the girl's
phone
and you were like oh my god someone
loves you they sent you this like
peanut butter cookie thing and she goes
that's my own number i sent it to myself
it was
the funniest thing i was like the most
brutal moment and
so funny no it was so good i have the
cutest the cutest people come out
and the clubs are always like you have
the nicest fans i'm like that's so weird
because i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's so funny my when i do clubs
they're like your fans had their shoes
off and they're rubbing their feet
i was thinking like whose fans are bad
and then here
your friend your fans wrote i love annie
letterman and [ __ ] on the wall
okay and it's my brother's name you're
in um
everyone's been peeing in there there's
a lot of jizz stains i don't know what
it is
wait i'm dying to hear about the comedy
story though okay so bobby was there too
right
it was so i didn't see him i was on the
next night was it the same or different
it was it was it's different but it's so
good so it's
and i don't know what the or situation's
gonna be but so it was
two shows in the main room there was one
it's friday and one saturday
and the lineup was just really good it
was so fun i went after tim dillon and
just to be back there so
it's like in the main room which is
usually packed and then
the spots that i was getting put up
before disrespectfully usually after
some people that clear the room
i don't know if it was strategic but
it's disrespectful so usually i would go
up at late at night
and the audience half the audience or
more would be gone
and there'd still be a lot of people
there but they would be scattered around
in different areas and it just kind of
never
felt like connected so this even though
it was not at full capacity
it was still a good amount of people but
they were all placed like
evenly so it was so nice it just felt
really good
and in the green room i wanted they put
like a table on stage i don't know why
but like a waist level table and so tim
dillon and i are in the back
in the green room and he goes
we're talking about how much new york
it's like we couldn't imagine ever
living in new york again because we
started common together in new york
he's like yeah imagine going up four
flights of st stairs right now and i was
like well it wouldn't be as hard for me
as it would be for you tim
and he goes well it's a little harder
than it used to be huh annie and
i have not laughed so hard in my life
like it was like i'm back
[ __ ] and then like my whole he went
before me and he stood behind the table
and i came out and i was like tim why
don't you stand in front of the table
like
below your waist is the skinny part and
it was just like these sort of like hits
at each other just felt so good
the audience was just so awesome i just
really was in the moment i don't know
you probably feel this way too it's like
less like pressure than i used to put on
myself
yeah and you were doing a special right
before the pandemic so doing
i mean that's like so like having to hit
the exact jokes every time
and i just realized how much like weird
pressure i was putting on myself it's
like we're the funny thing right it's
not like
our words are coming from us so i just
made this pact with myself that it's
like i'm just gonna be in the moment and
be my funniest i can possibly be and not
worry about like
what words go where and it just was
really good i did a whole bunch of
new jokes and it was just really fun was
it the same kind of thing where people
comedians could kind of come and hang
out or no
no there was like maybe a couple in the
in the parking lot but they were i think
working it was like
there were like maybe five people out i
think i'm gonna do it this weekend i was
i was like
it looks like cool no definitely do it
yeah so good i mean i would i would go
back
obviously i'm gonna do i'm doing a set
wednesday
night so
yeah you want to come we'll get you in
but that's another thing like that used
to be my big like move with people i'd
be like i'll get you into the comedy
store and now because it's kovid
i can't do it which is kind of a
blessing too because it's i always
overextend and i'm like inviting every
[ __ ] packet
i never invite any my bank tellers you
know me
don't run errands with annie unless you
want to not
see your bed for a few days because
you'll be out all day
i used to live in a really like busy
like populated area in brooklyn
and just walking to the coffee shop
would take me just hours because i'd run
into so many people
i like talking you're very much um
mayoral
gubernatorial like in a different life i
think you would have
been a great politician you're very good
with just making conversation with
people
i want to be a mate i want to be the
mayor of my hometown
well let's do it dave won't move
do you have to be a resident can you be
a virtual leader
all right guys we asked you for
questions on our instagram
and you came through so here they are
what is the dumbest way that you've
injured yourself mine personally
is sneezing into a wall
somehow and almost knocking myself out
and that was brenna hi bryna
that's cute esther's like you think
that's silly
i mean annie knows mine i was really
excited about a new episode of 20 20.
i got in bed to watch it i didn't have
my glasses i got up i ran into the other
room to get my glasses and i hit my foot
on a foam roller
and i broke my [ __ ] toe and that was
the first
time she'd use exercise equipment in 10
years
and that's a really stupid injury
i mean she really foam rollers are also
like kind of known for their like
lightness yes it was like
i don't know how it happened and i've
never broken a bone before when i
when esther said she broke her toes like
can i please guess which toe
i knew it was the baby toe i knew it
what about you guys stupid injuries
the dumbest thing i ever did was take um
um a skateboard up the very top of a
hill and my friend was in an electric
scooter and we were camping
in san diego so this was at a campsite i
found the biggest hill
because i thought that i was like a
legitimate skater and i wasn't
and i bombed this hill and then this
couple
came out of nowhere with her two
chihuahuas and i superman into the
concrete
and i had gravel from the top of my head
to my toes and i've spent
all three days camping trying to pluck
[ __ ] out of my hands
and i had my road rash on my titties
like my
i almost lost the nipple when i got out
yeah in my scooter accident
mine my all both my nipples were just
like
that was my pick up line i would go
together do you want to rub neosporin on
my titty
i would pull out the tube yeah no i did
a lot of stuff like that like i
definitely
you know drove things drunk i shouldn't
have um oh
in hawaii one time i broke my toe from
a [ __ ] hydra flask oh yeah you
dropped i did
yeah the most l.a thing happened to me
on vacation i had a hydro flask of ice
girl not l.a that's like a basic white
girl i had a white girl moment then
because i was coming out of the beach
and it was hooked onto my finger it
dropped it fell on my toe it broke my
toe and i
almost passed out from the pain and i
remember telling my sister
you gotta go get the car you gotta drive
it back this way because i can't take
another step like it knocked the wind
out of me
and um i remember bobby saying like
how'd you break your toe i'm like i
can't tell you
i simply can't tell you i um
i fell off my bunk bed my parents
reminded me of this when i was
at summer camps the boy camp we stayed
in these pavilions so they were already
off the ground about this much
and then i was on the top bunk so then
on top of that
then the floor then the bunk then the
other bunk i mean i was like
many feet off the ground and i rolled
out of the bunk onto
a the um root of a tree i must have been
like 12 and i just
had the wind knocked out for two weeks
of camp just like
that was the funniest bachelor episode i
had ever seen it was the bachelorette
when one of the male contestants had to
be
taken to the hospital because he fell
off of his bunk beds in the middle of
his sleep
and like he [ __ ] his face up like he
was like you're not awake to protect
yourself
in the fall you're just like you fall
the real fall
when i was a baby and we were on
vacation back before my parents
lost all their money um we were on
vacation and i was in one of those
little like we were at dinner
those little high chairs or whatever the
kids are in and i don't know how
but i tumbled out of it and we were
eating tacos
and were you trying to get some that
fell on the ground i was like a tiny
baby
and when i hit the ground the tacos like
made that crunch
and my parents were like oh she's dead i
thought it was like your skull
like it was so traumatizing for my
family but i just had like a
you know like a bruised lip i actually
looked really sexy you're like hi
you're a happiness really sexy i'd say
you're still a hot baby i don't want to
be
weird about it i remember um being
having a
mild religion it wasn't that mild an
allergic reaction to something i'd eaten
probably eggplant and bobby saying that
i had never been hotter because like my
lips like puffed up a lot
my friend who works on um i guess i can
say this when i was working with
sasha baron cohen my friend that works
with him
they had to do something for one of the
movies where they um wanted to inject
like
saline into their lips to make like it
might have been bruno something to have
like really big lips
but he was like the guinea pig the
producer my friend that works
and so and he like he showed me this
picture from these like big
i was like you honestly look like
gorgeous like i don't know how to like
tell you like you look
i mean lips that were this i was like
this is like the most attractive way
that's amazing can we why don't they do
saline in the lips
i'm not sure i think that it does a lot
like i think he was in a lot of pain and
it was like a
ah yeah i i think that you would
probably just absorb it into your body
very quickly
i imagine because it's just saline yeah
it's so like when you want to like i do
want to be like this hippie that's like
how we look is the best and then every
once in a while you
like get the your lips get so chapped
that they kind of swell and you i look
[ __ ]
or like you know you get a cold and your
voice gets a little like oh this is hot
like
any little alteration you get sick and
you see a rib cage
what's the next question george okay
seriously
and genuinely what do you guys think
is the hottest thing about yourself
and don't turn this into a [ __ ] joke
and why did esther
pretend to be someone else
that's from dana what's her name hi dana
physical we're going physical right yeah
physical yeah
okay i know mine actually it's very easy
[ __ ] no esther it's my
it's my it sounds like i'm flexing
because it is but that's the question i
really
have really nice breasts
i can confirm and i really want to tweak
those nipples
no [ __ ]
that's why i got these nails not to
scratch your head to scratch your
boob hair i also like my lips and my
nose
great boobs great lips great nose great
ass great ass
great everything especially good waist
great ways
cute belly like cute little i told you
you got the little donut
what's your favorite thing about is that
the question mm-hmm
sexiest thing about my favorite thing
about me
i do like a lot i know your yours is
easy
what my butt your ass i like my tits
though too i really like all of it but i
feel like you have like a
like you're known for your ass i have a
good butt
i don't know how it's going to age i
don't know where it's at i'm at that
place now where
butts don't eat but yes they do angel
but yes they do you're just a couple
years younger
oh my god do they age really enjoy this
time because things are just different i
don't know they
like i always i always think that like
and this is no
no dis to all the moms out there but i
always feel like sometimes what happens
is the baby pulls the butt cheeks out
with them no i don't know but but asses
but then i realized it's not the baby
it's just age i think
and asses fall on men too on men
i mean boy do they fall on me my dad's
ass wow
wow it's gotten even flatter it's
unbelievable is there any way to pro is
there prevention
yeah work out prophylaxis
squats saline what else annie your eyes
i like my eyes
i like my nose i like my mouth
i like my tits i like my butt
i like my thighs my calves i used to not
like i like them now
my feet boy are you guys missing out
they are
gorgeous i yeah no i'm just over not
liking myself i like my whole body
i'd like to get fit though your voice is
good my voice is good my jokes are
[ __ ] great
yeah my boyfriend's cool my friends are
cool i don't know producers are awesome
it's really just a good life i like
bananas i don't know everything's good
she's in a mania i'm about to get my ass
beat
she just turns around yeah i like
everything except esther's no what did
you say you like her lips and her nose
just destroy the things you like about
yourself um i
really really love my big cheeks and my
jawline
oh yeah my big cheeks i know for a fact
people
pay to have big cheeks you have a
wonderful face my mother has big cheeks
it's something that i was very insecure
about when i was younger because i
just was very like round up here but i
love them now
i don't know why i ever hated them and i
would be devastated if my cheeks got
taken away and i like my jawline a lot
you have that
your cheeks and your jaw are impeccable
thank you exquisite
we all have big cheeks that was
unrelated
i feel like it was related you were
getting so you were kind of kegeling
like you were seeing
you were looking at kalil's because you
were keegan you guys have to teach she
had a kegel i was
it's a muscle that's hard it's hard i
you that's how i orgasm i keegle real
hard
and then it gets me there really fast
you come in three seconds
will you teach me how to do it yeah
maybe holy you know what you do you put
your finger inside me and i'll keegall
and then
you put your you're gonna feel this
you're gonna feel this it's gonna
capture your finger
can i put it on a glove or go through
the underwear you can go gloveless baby
that's like all is permitted that i feel
like i'll get in trouble
with the old what if i asked dave dave
look this is strictly for
experimental purposes it will actually
help him
i'm just trying to teach her how to
properly no it would help him because
you never kegel on a dick that gets so
excited it's so funny because of yoni
eggs i always was like you guys you
don't need a yoni egg just use a dick
it makes your partner look really happy
do you want to call him
now yeah like we can call him now here
i'm gonna hand it off to you
he's gonna answer he should be like
there's been an accident
hi dave it's kalylah hello
hi i've dreamed of dave
speaking to me like that um i have a
question esther wanted me to pose to you
would you be okay with her
for experimental purposes um sticking
her finger
up my vagina to show her what a kegel
um exercises what is going on right now
is this am i on the podcast you are and
she insisted that i call you and ask
dessert
it was a natural it was a natural call
she didn't insist i insisted that i
because she we're talking about like a
female exercise called kegeling
and she's like i don't know how to kegel
and i was like wait it's the easiest
thing she's like how do i learn i'm like
look basically the only way to know how
to contract
is to feel the contraction yourself so i
said from a medical standpoint all we
really have to do is
for you to you know dave i just want to
be clear
i offered to wear a glove and she told
me not to
and that's why she that's why i work
hard so i just want to know what you
think
i think that this is like no longer a
podcast and this has become
something else that is like unfamiliar
to me i want to support it but it's also
like something is happening over there
that is that transcends
podcasts it's it only fans
i guess my first reaction is
i trust esther and i appreciate that
she's calling me
or you're calling me to check on this
i don't love it but i also
don't see how it's not going to happen
eventually it won't be to that it's not
a
yeah this is a in the foreseeable future
it's a very very not a sexual thing it's
more
it's very educational esther by the way
didn't realize that she was putting her
chapstick on getting ready
she's now going back she's like oh it's
not happening
like something started educational and
then it's like
oh wait hold on a second that's
porn i'll make sure that
um i'll sign a contract i'll sign a
contract saying it will never escalate
forbidden love clandestine but i will
consider it all your points dave and i'm
gonna pass you back to esther and we
will reconsider
um this all of this all right
bye dave we love you dave dave you're
king
dave's like when he answers when he's
excited to hear someone's voice itself
neither of us have ever heard that i've
gotten it a few times and you know i
remember them
you can never take those two times i
love dave i i have regrets because i
want i
i really do yearn for dave's respect i
feel like you have it
it's so annoying yeah you unfortunately
you do have it
i have to like show i'm like i worked
for it doesn't help that i worked on the
sasha show okay
i give him my credits like he tries so
hard when
the day she got a big laugh from dave
was a really
special forever i really i but i ruined
it because i kept bringing it up do you
remember like two minutes ago when you
laughed at my joke and i said this and
then you laughed
that was the day that we told him we
were gonna do the podcast
i know we're gonna become podcast stars
and he's like yeah right
and then look at us now he wasn't like
yeah right but david
he just doesn't live in the podcast
world he also doesn't ever want to deal
with me
being disappointed because of how
horrible i am
so he he's always trying to keep me low
like keep low expectations low
expectations so i don't crash
i don't know i hate that i like faking
it like let's fake it
let's just fake it let's pretend we
already got it looks like
let's buy crab legs with our last 15
dollars
it's like crazy like asked her how many
times was i eating crab legs over the
pandemic where
no money was being made it was it was a
serious issue
like a few of us were starting to cut
like huddle together and be like we need
an intervention
she's eating coffee again you can't take
them from me you'll never i'm just
throwing butter at them like no
so this has been our show i'm esther
that over there is kalila with the
beautiful cheeks and over here with a
big
ass is annie juicy and swampy
yeah bye guys we'll see you next time
bye thank you
enjoy your wet dreams
you